my daughters are six and eight they have
plenty of friends their age but we have
cousins and we hang out with a lot of
older kids i have never i mean literally
teenagers going
he's coming on your show it was the most
exciting thing
and i was like yes he is
and i'm in the beauty game i've been in
it for
you know over a decade i started with
covergirl
and then got to build my own brand
called flour in fact
i'm actually gonna send this to you
because this was a product
that was priced out for us as too
expensive and i fought for it and i fell
on the sword and sometimes that does not
work out
and every once in a while i think that's
where you get lucky
and it's our number one selling product
and has been now for almost two years so
i would give anything to send it to you
and get a review you can post it or
sidebar with me because what i love is
you are honest you do not
mince words and you are truthful
where do you think you got the
confidence to be
truthful and have real people's backs
rather than pandering to brands when i
started my channel i
came to this pivotal crossing point
where i realized okay hiram you can
either be
brutally honest and never be able to
work with brands and never really get
any business opportunities or
you can you know try to um you know
pander to
whatever the industry wants in order to
have business opportunities and it
was a it was a very quick decision for
me to just say
no i want to be honest i want to be
completely authentic and if it means i
don't get any business opportunities
so be it and the amazing thing is that
the industry has really shifted where
i'm seeing brands who are really
being a lot more open to honest and
authentic feedback and it's amazing
because i view my
feedback and my opinions as hopefully an
opportunity for the brand to grow and
learn how they can better be
accessible by a larger audience and
cater to more people so
it truly is a win-win situation and it's
something that i thought would disable
me
but actually has enabled a lot of
opportunities
i cannot tell you how special
that is i love that you know what you're
getting with you
and i think to take that kind of a risk
as a business person
to say i'm gonna risk it all to be
honest
that's crazy because you could have
really hurt yourself
and instead you went on top for
being truthful thank you for your words
i'm so grateful that it's been received
so well
um okay what uh would you recommend to
all of the people that are freaking out
that i'm talking to
right now is there any product that you
would say
try uh think in the ranges of like 15 to
25.
oh that is a great question i would
probably have to say
i personally really like retinol
treatments um just because of the uh
the repair i've seen within my own skin
when i was 18 years old i really
struggled with
premature aging and so i started using
retinol treatments specifically from
brands like the ordinary
and cerave and the inky list
so if i were to recommend one i'd say
like the in keyless retinal serum is
great
because it's gentle it's effective it's
a great introductory retinol to start
um you know repairing that damage within
the skin but it's priced at about ten
dollars
so it's a really competitive price
that's pretty accessible by everyone
that's perfect um how do you
try products in time frames successions
and spaces in between
yeah absolutely so i would recommend
only substituting out one product at a
time if you're trying something new so i
typically will rely on my tried and true
products that i know work
well for my skin and then introduce one
product so that i'm not trying to guess
which specific product gave me those
good results
and typically i would say to anyone who
is starting a new product
wants to see if it works for their skin
is not sure if you're going to see
long-term results
i usually recommend two months and if
you still haven't seen any results for
two months then
i would say that's a good time to try
something new but that's usually a good
amount of time to be able to figure out
if it's going to work for your skin or
not
all right i gotta be more patient with
things because i'm like
after a few days i'm like on to the next
one
how do you feel and what would you say
to a younger generation
that is seeing a lot of filters and
enhancements
how do you feel about that yeah you know
i
feel like it's it's difficult especially
right now and definitely for gen z i
i the the pressures to have like perfect
skin for example
um are kind of ridiculous because it's
not a constant
it's impossible to constantly have
perfect skin
and i look at skin care instead of from
a beginning to end result trying to
accomplish
one type of skin as more of an enjoyable
journey something that you should enjoy
partaking in something that should be
meditative in nature
really enjoyable when you're
experiencing it and if your approach to
skin care
falls within that specific area it's
going to be a lot more enjoyable than
trying to attain something that's
truthfully impossible to attain well
listen i just thank you so much for
coming on the show you're such a hero to
so many people
and it's really exciting to get to talk
with you today and
um thank you so much thank you so much
i love what you're doing keep pushing
for looking at yourself positively and
please tell your daughters hi for me oh
my gosh
you have no idea how popular i
am for getting to talk to you and uh
thank you
hiram really and truly follow him on
tick tock if you're not
already and youtube you're
all the rage and you're helping guide us
every step of the way
thank you so much